eva und marc freuen sich auf ihr kennt
doch diese schwangerschaft ist nicht
unbeschwert
vor einem jahr ist die tochter des
paares kurz vor der geburt gestorben
es mag jetzt vielleicht blöd klingen
aber ich kann eigentlich bis zum schluss
kauf dass die stadt wäre das sicherlich
lauter ängste begleiten das kann durch
die schwangerschaft
[Musik]
der salbe konzentriere sich selber ich
spüre ich finde das gut einfach das
schon groß aber in ordnung wird dass das
körpergefühl das buch viel los
[Musik]
das ist so typisch
eine familie gründen das hat sich das
paar aus dem zürcher oberland schon
immer gewünscht
in drei monaten soll ihr zweites kind
zur welt kommen
wir einfach das gefühl dass
das thema die richtige ist monstrum gott
familie gründe für mich die hand vor ort
eigentlich zeigt dass mich hin möchten
und für uns ist das so es gehört für usa
einfach spitze lieder zu
kürzen ja
heute ist ein besonderer tag
der erste geburtstag ihrer tochter miley
miley ist ein sternenkind
sie starb kurz vor der geburt völlig
unerwartet im bauch der mutter
für mich wichtig dass man das was man
daran denkt was sie ist von mir ja
doch ein star
muss das werden ins kraut es ist toll
hier
[Musik]
von dem moment
muss der mieter ins gras
[Applaus]
meine geliebte tochter marie heute ist
ein erster geburtstag im himmel
eigentlich sollten wir jetzt alle
zusammen an einem tisch sitzen und
dann erst kuchen essen
[Applaus]
anstelle dessen stehen wir nun hier mit
einer handvoll luftballons und einem
kleinen bruder im bauch
dazu eine ganze gästeliste dann einen
kleinen stern und freude die medien mit
feiern du fehlst uns so sehr kleine
prinzessin wir besuchen heute an
wunderschönen tag zu verbringen die ich
immer ganz neu dabei wir feiern einen
tag denn es ist ein geburtstag
wir lieben dich deine eltern
[Musik]
moskau
[Applaus]
ok
[Musik]
die großmutter mütterlicherseits
zuschauer im waldfriedhof begraben
nicht gerade die menschen vor dem
eigentlichen waldstück
es hat aber auch seine gedanken dass da
schon für ihre wieder neue wachstum
bringen
[Musik]
ich habe letztes jahr für
beherrscht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ist dieser raum ist
um jetzt erfahren haben dass selbst im
schlaf oder gar nicht im kreis möchte
sich heute aber auch die erste aktion
habe das drehbuch rolle des kinos mehr
user
und der hand sowie südlich an einer sehr
guten
halt einfach von hand für den 12 für
nach erholung sowohl aber alles für
psyche ist es ist es besser in normalen
geburt
wurde
ich bin sehen wir schon an die kommunen
sie dort kam es da sehr gut unterstützt
sicher nichts für die ihre mittlere
normale geburt vom analogen dahinter
aber das ist sicher schenkt sie haben
sie auf ganz natürlichem weg energie
nicht mehr so ja
also dresden kritik sie jetzt tief
standen und so vieth und
ja
der zweite gedanke ist
das mag jetzt vielleicht blöd klingen
aber ich neige dich bis zum schluss kauf
dass der staat stelle tatsächlich lappe
das ist
wunschdenken
etwas das ich sehr oft dankbar sind die
lange zeit war sie aber haben das ist
sehr speziell ist
mir irgendwie
fahrer nicht und
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das sei jedes kilo das haus nicht
beeinflusst das passiert einfach
man hat jetzt hat jetzt siege
untersuchungen machen und matze hat dies
passiert und ich denke es ist einfach
wenn wir das so erkannt
sozusagen wieder einmal vor augen führe
nicht selbstverständlich dass es ist
dass man lagert das lux und sind die
traurigen erfahrungen haben das paar
geprägt deshalb lässt sich eva in der
schwangerschaft medizinisch engmaschig
begleiten
ich liebe irgendwann einfach ganz groß
ist dass irgendwas nicht in ordnung ist
die 23 jährige hat nicht nur ein kind
tot zur welt gebracht sondern bereits
sechs fehlgeburten in der
frühschwangerschaft erlitten
die angst um einen weiteren kind verlust
begleitet durch die schwangerschaft
ja
ja ja
so
und jetzt
passiert
mit ihr besser
fertig
also bewegen
evas gebärmutter form erschwert es den
befruchteten eizellen sich einzunisten
eine operation war geplant doch es kam
anders diese schwangerschaft kam
dazwischen und hat gehalten es sind noch
13 wochen bis zum geburtstermin
medizinisch ist alles in ordnung mentale
unterstützung bietet alessia an
sie ist eine durch eine ausgebildete
schwangerschaft und geburt begleiterin
die beiden frauen verbindet eine
ähnliche geschichte
alles unterstützung kann das paar gut
gebrauchen
lange haben wir wirklich kommt man dahin
der bislicher gedruckt
juli heißt übersetzt dem dienerin der
frau und ich finde ausdruck rem
schlimm schlimm
ist mir zu angebracht ich bin nicht
religiös ich sag dem leben für den gfc
selbst in dem sich und
sind stark schöne freundschaft meistens
wurden hat doch irgendwann wieder
verbietet oder nicht so intensiv
ich freue mich wo
begleitet während der schwangerschaft
geburt und wenn gewünscht im wochenbett
und sich
nicht medizinisch also es ist einfach
wirklich nur begleitet vom board vor der
frau vor allem im winter wenn
irgend möglich ist und dass man dann
wirklich an händler und nicht mehr die
großen umsätze sondern das ist
bewusst
dass er
sich habe da wurde unter sport
einfach dass sie dass sie wieder seither
aber es ist alles okay ist heiß und dann
einfach zwischen
danach
ok so und das finde sagt
großteil der wasser hilft dann
wenn man da nicht lange diskutieren
hatte für das muss auch gemacht
jan ich danke für dich dass du unter der
geburt ein konzert ist
aber dass er macht einfach mit der
ganzen sache zu tun
haben halt die ein oder andere emotionen
dann doch einmal mit je nachdem ob
mama ist das nicht denn
[Musik]
koste tiefster stufe so 18 noch nach der
geburt kann
was ich mache
doch wie
alles jahr hat auch ein sternenkind ihr
drittes kind ist während der geburt
gestorben völlig unerwartet nach einer
problemlosen schwangerschaft
[Applaus]
sind und ich weiß aber etwas verlangt
wird komplettiert wird das gemeinsame
schicksal schweißt zusammen
und hilft mit der situation umzugehen
bei der arbeit mit den pferden findet
eva ruhr und schöpft kraft
und ich
bin
also
konzentriere sich selber ich spüre ich
finde das gut einfach das scheint
einfach enorm dass das gefühl das ist
viel los
er ist jetzt genug geld
ich rede mit der forderung skulptur
hat da was man dir schlicht zu stark ist
ich sah mich aber für geburt normal
schwierigem einsetzbarer küsse
kontrollen über muskulatur aber zu viel
muskulatur die schau mich zwar schwierig
also jetzt ruf erarbeitet hat mir
wirklich am meisten umgang mit ross
kurve zieht für bringe aber nur auf der
wii und fotoapparat machen und einfach
im stolz
[Musik]
immer man gerade unterwegs
außerirdisches gerade glücklich oder im
weg je nach größe schwangerschaft
shooting
und mit mega schönen morgens ohne noch
am sihlsee
[Musik]
natürlich im mittel
geschätzt nicht unbedingt man schaut
immer wieder mit einer gedanke da
ist alles in ordnung
kunz gut oder gut
das begleitet ein natürlich
ja es ist halt gerade so an dass lily
in ruhigere tage hat einfach mal schläft
man dann halt dann einfach wieder
möglich sind so
okay es ist jetzt nur einen raum an
ihnen nach dreieinhalb stunden findet es
okay ich schon einmal mit mit dem
doppelherz den kontrolliert wirklich
alles okay ist das einfach auch nicht
nur wunderbar
einiges gute gefühl hat sondern ihres
berufs sehr einfach beruhigt ist und
wieder schon sagen okay mal als ich es
ist alles in ordnung
die herztöne abhören das beruhigt
[Musik]
einfach zum lebherz frequenzen uhr
kirche
gerade wenn also auch die ruhigeren
klängen nicht bewegt aber auch zum 01
und
beide haben ihre eigenen strategien mit
ihren ängsten umzugehen
in der aktuellen raum hebt der
32-jährige markup
sierra nevada unterwegs also
dass ich jetzt in militärische
simulation in sierra nevada zum beispiel
amerikanischer trainingsplan und wir bei
dir
kampfeinsatz
[Musik]
es nimmt der ruf als pitts lied
unsicherheit
vor der geburt und nervosität
natürlich
gerade mit der vr brille und jetzt da
hat auch halt in eine
völlig andere welt ist
ein flugzeug beginnen das natürlich
besonders als im alltag
[Musik]
bismarck ist für mich das gefühl vor
hoch es ist aber
konstanter da und man fühlt sich wohl
und egal wo man ist wenn er wie ich
fühle ich mich die haie und das ist es
auch für mich
dass wir zeigen konnten dass er richtig
ist zum zum der reste vom labor mit ihm
aber sowas partnerschafts verbringen ich
bin immer noch mal überlegt ich das
selbe antwort das ist sehr viel geld
ja und da so ist ein alter
verschweigt ist das mit meiner idee ja
ja das sowieso es gibt andere bauermann
jetzt wo also wovon du mit einer schrieb
schon dreht das was das nicht so
bürgschaft an dem er ihr schicksal hat
eva zu einer neuen berufung geführt mit
ihrer erfahrung will sie in zukunft
andere unterstützen
ich bin momentan also aus wittlich draht
zur begleiterin speziell für sterne
eltern und möchte cbf
steinwandel mutterschaftsurlaub dann
durch
durch ein sterne ältere traf machen
das verzerre die eltern gern vor ihre
kinder und sich halt einfach sehr
speziell ein hausrind nett und hat nicht
die möglichkeit zum so viel geschichte
erzähle und 1000 bis jetzt endlich
geschafft und das was ich jetzt 31 hat
ist erst mal probiert oder ja das kam
mir hat alles nicht wir uns halt immer
das spezielle die gleiche geschichte
aber zum teil neue sachen wo heute
zuhört wenn man halt wieder das was es
ist zeit habe ich und ewigen erst maria
fally oder wallace flock und vielleicht
und andere ältere verstimmt deshalb will
ich wieder so gut dass alles enorm viel
bedeutet die dem avant finde ich das
auch
schwachsinnig wäre möglich als 16
haupt oder nicht was nach dem tod ist
aber für die älteren wo der glaube und
die zeichen gesehen und worden ist es
enorm schön wenn es das machen könnte
teile
marie hat ihren festen platz im leben
des paares
immer wieder baut eva rituale in ihren
alltag hin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dass sie ja das ja
was sie die waldner dafür so kennenlerne
dass mir sie würde so dafür zeigen
auch in alisas leben ist das verstorbene
kind ihr sohn evan präsent der mehr das
thema ob sie wenn ich es klingt auf trab
bringen ist das läppert sich lappe das
ist dass ich dort lagert das rund
newsletter das klingt wie diese familie
hat sie ist einfach
die pure lebensfreude und dann ist
einfach dass ich auch
nützlichen kolter mensch und das ist
für die ganze familie das ganze umfeld
[Musik]
das ist also wirklich du tust du ihnen
trug und wissen deutsches brot das
zimmer es hat das ist alles parat
gestanden und das ist finde ich es von
uns steckt sie
[Musik]
zieht mit dem verstorbenen kind heißt
für mich in erster linie
viele menschen und ihren toten mann oder
kann sich nicht vorstellen dass das das
dass man sich hinten berührt mit armen
über
stunden mit ihnen verbringen
und und aufsicht gezählt es überhaupt
nicht das ist nämlich dem vorsätzlich
und in sony ericsson und mira generiert
welche dollar fordere ich bin und
niemals tagsüber mit dem moment der hand
hat und mich zu meinem sohn ohne gefährt
hat und dass ich mir so extrem wichtig
nicht das was ich jetzt fühle mich aber
ich glaube es war anders wenn ich das
erlebt
immer mehr stürme eltern nehmen
professionelle hilfe in anspruch
viele betroffene bilden sich weiter
teilen ihre eigenen erfahrungen und
leisten unterstützung
im rahmen des vereins himmels kind
leistet alles jahr akut begleitung bike
ins verlust sie und ihr team sind rund
um die uhr abrufbar
für mich schlapp und eis kürzer und
darum
ist das auch so schön wie das von medien
und harmonisieren und
kommt aus dass die zahl post und verdi
zusammen und sind schöne für die beiden
häufig fdp 7 wenn der erste atemzug
gemacht wird und ich bin an der
lithologischen das ist ja
wichtig menschen geburt begleitet mache
ich mir persönlich das ist schon
so dass ich sie
gebracht hat
eva ist jetzt in der 36
schwangerschaftswoche
ich
bin nicht billig zu tun begleiterin
die ärztliche betreuung ist intensiv
das kindlein soll kurz vor dem
eigentlichen geburtstermin auf die welt
kommen
hat ja von meiner tochter und
darum haben wir jetzt aber auf nummer
sicher dass plazenta brauchte ich das
durch politik einfach nur voll
gewährleistet ist das aber auch wirklich
nikon gfk
akupunktur soll eva auf die geburt
vorbereiten
heute soll es losgehen anspannung und
vorfreude steigen
[Musik]
wie lange sich
die werdenden eltern machen sich auf den
weg ins spital wetzikon
[Musik]
hallo das buch gefühl von mir ist so wie
gut ich denke dass grundsätzen alles so
wie es waren
und
ich hoffe dass man es nach dem
wochenende überstanden haben und nun ein
gewinn war der mahlower haben das dann
wie n fördernde medikamente unterstützen
die einsetzung der geburtswehen doch
geduld ist gefragt
wieso muss sie bereits 24 stunden sind
vergangen die wehen sind immer noch
schwach
und da ist einfach wieder motto mund
halten entwickelt
und existiert
ist verstärker und riskieren wer sturm
million
babys mit tabletten relativ uhr trauben
von dosieren meint die lange warterei
und
immer wird das gefühl jetzt kostenlos
als kostenlos und dann
wird weiter
fleißig es wieder ab und dann wartet mal
wieder
es ist ein langes warten
jetzt sehr falsch ich minuten weiß nicht
aber sie macht schon unter druck so
volkmer und typ ist und
[Musik]
endlich nach 48 stunden geht es los
hebamme ehemann und dura unterstützen
die werdende mutter
[Musik]
die wehen verlangen eva alles ab aber es
geht voran
[Musik]
gute trend von dem aus
geschafft
[Musik]
es sieht schon was schon
dann ist es soweit
david james baby ist da
[Musik]
mit dem klassiker
der kleine david benötigt unterstützung
bei der atmung
[Musik]
schnell wird klar
david muss auf die neonatologie nach
winterthur
noch am selben abend wird er verlegt
es sind bange stunden für die eltern
der dollar sei auch zum verarbeiten
größerer fortsetzung gekommen und
schrien abtransportiert wird und
die habe ich das und
blattwerk sie familienzimmer und
wirklich dabei und
dazu einen finden und unter drei umsatz
büro mit dem familienleben ist alles was
ich mache psychisch teils nach damit
nicht ganz einfach aber dominiere darwin
darum wie man am beispiel voran und wird
sonst sieht bei einigen
war super ist
ziemlich
bieten hat gestanden das ist sehr schön
als absoluter traum vom gewinn
[Musik]
hat
und sieht dann kenne ich das man darf an
die
hoffentlich
aus der geplanten woche auf der
neonatologie sind zehn lange tage
geworden
atemnot syndrom
dass ich in
probleme und
gelungen auch wenn sie noch nicht ganz
praktisch für zum können nach eröffnung
und schöne pläne probleme
die sind für die unternehmen
in berlin nach geburt senat um hilfe
braucht und mühe hat mit stufen und das
wird sie als mami oder papi gebiet lust
hat nicht gefragt von schuld oder nicht
das ist schön tun rief ihr oder separat
sie wieder lohne zum geburtstag
mitinhaber der euch die geschichte
wirklich abgeschlossen
und unternehmer also alles was es neue
gesichter
aus bisserl nervös
dass alles gut funktioniert aber
wirklich sehr sehr freudig
sachen machen setzte sich zum ersten mal
mit einem gesunden kind dürfen die
eltern das spital verlassen
[Musik]
mit dem stillen klappt es noch nicht so
ganz doch eva beschäftigt auch noch
etwas anderes
nach der geburt hat sich herausgestellt
dass ihre gebärmutter nicht operiert war
ist die seltene form der gebärmutter
kann immer wieder zu aborten führen
[Musik]
trotz dieser neuigkeit ist das cliq
überwältigend
[Musik]
wenn sich so ein herziger das ist ja und
halt einfach dass er das mega wunder ist
und ich fühle mich als mami extrem
aber mit wenig schlaf verwundet ist
das leben kann sehr fragil seien
und trotz zugang zu modernster medizin
bleibt der einfluss auf leben und tod
begrenzt
[Musik]
marburg